wenn ich quasi nur diskriminierende
Witze mache um zu provozieren dann muss
ich mich nicht wundern entgegenwind
kommen ich wusste natürlich es wird ein
Shitstorm geben es war kein Shitstorm es
war ein kritikstorm ja so eine Masse um
dich rum dich kritisiert ich persönlich
fand die Flut die dich danach getroffen
habe angemessen
worüber darfst du lachen über alles und
jeden oder braucht unser Humor Grenzen
bei mir sind heute Joyce ilk und Silvie
Carson die eine sagt es ist völlig okay
und lustig über ko tropfen Witze zu
machen die andere fühlt sich als Opfer
davon massiv attackiert
an manchen Stellen ist es für mein
Geschmack einfach zu wenig Reflexion ich
würde mir generell gesellschaftlich
wünschen dass wir einfach ein bisschen
sensibler mit Sprache umgehen
[Musik]
wo wir wirklich uns nicht einig sind ist
die Herangehensweise wie man
kommuniziert es könnte für den einen so
aussehen wie hört der Kommentar war doch
gar nicht so böse und für den anderen
hört man aber raus dass da vielleicht
eine leichte passive Aggressivität drin
ist weil Kritik etwas sehr sensibles ist
es geht um Meinungsfreiheit es geht um
cancel culture und vor allem darum wer
entscheidet was lustig ist und was nicht
Zeit für eine Paartherapie der Meinungen
zum Humor in Deutschland
[Musik]
ihr beiden herzlich willkommen danke
um euch mal zusammenzubringen oder habt
ihr schon mal überhaupt irgendwann in
echt gesprochen ja scheinbar hat es das
gebraucht ne ja also wir haben in echt
schon mal gesprochen aber nicht immer
sowas nee bevor es jetzt weitergeht und
ich verspreche euch schon das wird
wirklich heftig erstmal ein Gedanke die
beiden die so ein riesen schreiben
miteinander haben und so ein krasses
Thema in Deutschland überhaupt zur
Diskussion gebracht haben sind jetzt
heute hier treffen sich zum allerersten
Mal und wollen miteinander reden das ist
das Streit gibt es die Fetzen fliegen
ist glaube ich klar ich will vor allem
sehen ob die irgendwie auch bei diesem
Thema zusammenkommen die eine macht
einen Witz über k.o.-tropfen die andere
fühlt sich davon massiv angegriffen und
es soll heute um die Frage gehen darf
man über KO-Tropfen Witze machen deine
Meinung in einem Wort bevor
du was sagst du davon
Witze machen ja oder nein nicht interess
deine Meinung total bitte jetzt in die
Kommentare schreiben was du dazu sagst
je nach Kontext sind drei Worte aber
deine Meinung ja grundsätzlich schon
aber ich glaube ich würde mich da
anschließen
Konsens okay da gucken ob das so bleibt
jetzt sind wir voll in dem Thema eurem
ganz persönlichen Konflikt ich glaube
wenn meine Mutter zuguckt die wisst ihr
gar nicht was ist Phase deswegen werden
wir da jetzt mal tiefer einsteigen das
Aufräumen wir brauchen Platz in der
Mitte zusammen okay
hier ist schon jetzt direkt so viel
Konflikt in der Luft dass wir etwas
machen was wir in der Psychologie
schildert ein Action nennen ich gehe als
Psychologe als menschliches Schild
zwischen die beiden dann bekommen beide
erstmal Raum um zu beschreiben wo sie
überhaupt stehen
ihr sollt jetzt gleich eure Punkte
nennen dürfen erstmal einfach an Dich
adressiert die andere hört aber dabei zu
und kann danach auch darauf reagieren
wir werden dann also tauschen und wir
fangen an mit dir Joyce und ich habe
dazu den gerade schon angesprochenen
Konflikt mitgebracht
diesen Post um den es ging mit dem im
Grunde alles anfängt vielleicht magst du
mal kurz vorlesen
hat hier irgendwer von euch Eier
gefunden ich habe nur ein paar k.o
Tropfen bekommen frohe Ostern Hashtag
Partnerlook Herz Hashtag freedom of
Humer fangen wir damit mal erst mal an
zu wie tust du mir den Gefallen stellst
das einmal auf unsere kleine Staffelei
aber gerne
doch wir haben ja die Situation das Luke
Mockridge sich dem Vorwurf ausgesetzt
sah dass er in seinem Programm unter
anderem chaotropfen Witze benutzt hat
darauf hat sich dann der Gag bezogen was
aber dahinter lag war natürlich dann
noch mehr das habe ich dann noch nicht
genau gepackt magst du das mal
beschreiben was für dich dahinter lag
wusste natürlich dass das sehr provokant
war was ich nicht wollte ist damit
Opfern halt sagen dass das ist ja nicht
so schlimm und für mich wollte ich
vielleicht mir auch einfach zeigen ich
habe keine Angst vor öffentlichen ja vor
öffentlichen shaming oder was auch immer
von außen wahrscheinlich erstmal gar
nicht packen kann weil ich wusste
natürlich
Menschen damit verletze das war mir
nicht so bewusst und das war halt Kacke
jetzt kommen wir so viele die Ems rein
jetzt gibt's hier so viele Kommentare
hier geht's und jetzt klingelt das Handy
und wird alle rasten aus also privat
habe ich da jetzt nicht wirklich so böse
Sachen abbekommen
sehr viele Menschen die sich selber die
sagen ich hätte mich das nicht getraut
ich sehe das eigentlich so aber ich trau
mich das nicht weil eben dann in
Bewegung ist die irgendwo ein bisschen
vorgibt wie die Meinung in der
Gesellschaft zu also zu sein hat und die
sich dann eben nicht trauen das auch
öffentlich zu äußern ich will nicht
immer aufpassen müssen weil sofort
irgendwie Existenzen gefährdet sind
sondern dass man eigentlich die Chance
kriegt auch Fehler machen zu können und
sich auszutauschen und deswegen freue
ich mich ja auch das weiter hier sind
also für mich war das extrem schwer da
so zu sitzen und Sachen zu hören wo ich
so gerne was dazu gesagt hätte weil ich
dachte boah das ist jetzt schon wieder
das steht jetzt wieder so Kontext los im
Raum drunter steht Hashtag freedom of
humor was heißt das dann in dem Kontext
für dich
mega viel also was ich nicht mag ist
wenn Menschen ausgelacht werden oder so
da lache ich nicht mit das finde ich es
dann auch keine Art von Humor aber
grundsätzlich ist habe ich nicht bei
Humor eine Grenze für mich persönlich
verstehe das andere Menschen die haben
der Post ist jetzt noch online sehr viel
später du hast sie nicht gelöscht wird
ziehen so wieder raushauen
ich würde ihn so nicht wieder raushauen
genau und danach sind ja auch noch
andere Sachen von mir gepostet worden
unter anderem halt eine Entschuldigung
auch weil ich ja gemerkt habe dass das
so wie das stattgefunden hat ja nicht
sein sollte
der Post hinter uns der Witz über k.o
Tropfen magst du auch immer schildern
was aus deiner Sicht passiert ist was
der Kontext ist
also ich
mir ging es sehr schlecht danach also
weil ich selber quasi schon mal
betroffen war von k.o.-tropfen nämlich
vor kurzem Gefühle in dem Moment also
ich war einfach nur schockiert und dann
war ich komplett wieder in also in der
Situation wo ich halt damals war und
zwar dass ich eben aufgewacht bin
morgens nicht wusste was passiert ist
und ich dann zusammengebrochen bin
Nasenbluten hatte und wirklich also
rückblickend betrachtet habe ich danach
mal mit einem Experten gesprochen also
der RTW wurde auch gerufen von meiner
Nachbarin dann und
das war alles haarscharf also
k.o.-tropfen sind super gefährlich
letzte sterben können genau ich war halt
in diesem hilflosen Moment also wenn man
halt aufwacht ich weiß was passiert ist
das macht schon was mit einem also das
also mit mir machen genau man fühlt sich
so ein bisschen ausgeliefert so gut ja
wütend würde ich auf alle Fälle aber vor
allem weil das halt genau das
bagatellisiert weil es kann ja auch sein
dass ich mich über also dass ich Witze
über Tropfen mache aber das muss halt
schon richtig doll ausgefeilt sein so
dass dieser Witz auch greift aber das
hier das war ja schon also die Intention
dahinter würde ich jetzt vermuten und
das haben wir auch gelesen dann im
Nachgang war ja eigentlich nur aus
persönlichen Gründen um einem Freund
irgendwie ein besseres Image zu
verschaffen oder
sich selber da irgendwie zu präsentieren
und zu sagen mir ist eure Meinung egal
ich höre grundsätzlich super gerne zu
und ich lass super gerne jemand Ausreden
und guck erstmal was das mit mir macht
ich fand die Situation trotzdem
schwierig für mich einfach deswegen weil
ich keine Chance hatte dann noch mal zu
sagen ja aber so sehe ich das nicht das
was danach gekommen ist hat eigentlich
alles so so viel schlimmer gemacht und
beschreib mal was war da hatte ich da
provoziert ja also auch das was gerade
auch wieder so
geäußert wurde ist ist halt so ein sind
halt immer die gleichen Phrasen so ich
darf nicht mehr das sagen was ich will
ich habe Angst gecancelt zu werden ich
muss um meine Existenz fürchten das ist
ja faktisch nicht richtig weil Joyce
sitzt gerade hier und hat einen Job
obwohl sie
problematische Dinge gepostet hat und
auch ein luke mockrid hat ausverkaufte
heilen so also frage ich mich so ein
bisschen woher das kommt ist es weil man
die andere Meinung nicht aushalten kann
so weil natürlich kann ich mich frei
äußern aber man muss ja auch irgendwie
bedenken dass man auch andere Meinung
aushalten wenn man selber eine Meinung
äußern
komplett
täteropfer Umkehr das sagt sich
unglaublich leicht und dann ist klar der
eines der gute der andere ist der böse
natürlich gibt's Momente wo jemand klar
dass Opfer von etwas ist und trotzdem
gibt's ja auch ein riesenhaften
Graubereich wo man immer fragen muss ist
denn wirklich jemand das
Opfer also bevor wir direkt rufen Täter
Opfer Umkehr erstmal klären gibt es
einen Täter und gibt es einen Opfer
über ein getrennt durch mich als Schild
du zuerst Joyce jetzt du Silvie habt
sehr viel schon mal geäußert unglaublich
viel Einblicke geteilt aber eben
getrennt jetzt würde ich sagen kommen
wir wieder zusammen auf der Couch helft
ihm umzubauen
wo war der Moment wo du sagen würdest da
hätte ich direkt was sagen wollen
weil jetzt ist die Chance diese
existenziellen
Ängste wo du gesagt hast nee guck mal du
sitzt ja hier
ich glaube
Ängste sind ja auch nicht immer rational
die Menschen haben und ich glaube dass
es wirklich zum einen existenzielle
Angst dass die Menschen dazu bewegt sich
teilweise nicht authentisch mit ihrer
Meinung zu äußern ich glaube das ist so
ein bisschen was sehr oft dahinter liegt
im Internet dass man nicht weiß aber
dann ist wieder Nebensatz wo sich dann
viele Leute drauf stützen sich den
wieder falsch gesagt habe oder das heißt
auch nach dem Post den du gemacht hast
kam ja noch drei Statements und in ein
Statements ging es eigentlich nur darum
dass du am Ende das Opfer bist das
wollte ich nämlich gar nicht sagen
sondern eigentlich wollte ich auch das
gesamtgesellschaftliche Problem ich sehe
mich selber gar nicht als Opfer weil das
war eigentlich was was ich schon sehr
früh irgendwie
versucht hat zu verinnerlichen dass ich
eben nicht
Opfer bin oder mich als Opfer wahrnehme
sondern als eine selbstbewusste Frau ich
habe Feedback bekommen von also von
Leuten die nicht in der Öffentlichkeit
stehen die gesagt haben hey ich trau
mich nicht dann Post positiv zu
kommentieren obwohl ich das gerne würde
weil ich Angst habe vor den negativen
Kommentaren weil jeder der positiv
kommentiert hatte hat direkt irgendwie
zehn negative Kommentare darunter gehabt
und teilweise wirklich unterirdisch die
Frage ist worüber sprechen wir und da
möchte jetzt noch mal genauer reingehen
weil wir fragen uns ja was darf Humor
worüber darf gelacht werden und Joyce
von dir kam danach der Kommentar mein
Humor hat wenig Grenzen und dazu stehe
ich auch lasst uns über diese Grenzen
mal genauer sprechen weil du sagst bei
dir wird eine Grenze überschritten du
sitzt da reagierst massiv würdest du
jetzt sagen okay in dem Moment muss dann
einfach der freedom of you mal
beschnitten sein bis hierhin und nicht
weiter also ich fand es sehr angemessen
wie Menschen reagiert haben ich fand
auch das Ausmaß an Kommentaren und die
Flut die dich danach getroffen hat
angemessen gesellschaftlich gesehen dass
du darunter also du sagst ja du hast
jetzt nicht darunter so gelitten das
finde ich sehr gut weil Hass finde ich
sowieso immer Kacke so können alle
unterschreiben aber kurz im Verständnis
es gibt einen Witz über KO-Tropfen es
ist halt ja ich weiß aber es war ja als
Witz gedacht worüber wir lachen können
wäre jetzt genau die Frage und dann
kommt der Shitstorm wo du jetzt sagst
genau richtig ja was heißt Shitstorm ich
finde es war kein Shitstorm es war ein
Kritik Storm in meiner Wahrnehmung war
es so dass die meisten Kommentare sehr
langsam ausführlich und sehr konstruktiv
waren wenn dir ganz viele Menschen sagen
dass du vielleicht ein Fehler gemacht
hast dann ist es doch gar nicht so
verkehrt darüber mal nachzudenken ob das
stimmt und vielleicht sich dafür auch
wirklich zu entschuldigen so ganz
ernsthaft das war nicht vergessen auch
die Masse an Kritik wenn die einen
Menschen trifft das was macht auch was
wenn alle ja so eine Masse um dich
kritisiert mir fehlt es ja so ein
bisschen an Verhältnismäßigkeit wenn
Menschen Fehler machen und wenn es klar
ein Fehler ist
es steht das immer noch im Verhältnis
was danach dann passiert diesen Menschen
du hast gerade zurecht gefragt ist es
denn überhaupt ein Witz von dir was als
Witz gemeint es steht auch drunter
Freiheit für den Humor man darf über
alles lachen man muss über alles lachen
ist da was dran
also natürlich ist es so dass jeder über
alles lachen kann wann er will und via
will da schränkt einen ja auch keiner
eine deswegen gibt es also dieses
freedom of you more dass das beschnitten
wird ist halt einfach nicht wahr
aber man muss natürlich damit rechnen
dass wenn man eine diskriminierende
Haltung hat und das als Witz verkauft
dann das dann eben Leute laut werden im
Internet und weil eben ja Minderheiten
mittlerweile auch eine Stimme bekommen
online bleibt halt dagegen Wind nicht
aus ich glaube wir haben rechtlich
gesehen diese Meinungsfreiheit und
Kunstfreiheit und jeder kann das machen
rechtlich gesehen ich glaube aber
dadurch dass was wichtig ist
Minderheiten oder gewisse Gruppen sich
stark machen wollen für etwas aber das
vielleicht auf eine Art und Weise macht
die andere einschüchtern die sich nicht
mehr ihre Meinung zu sagen
weil ich glaube das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt du sagst es gibt in
Deutschland jetzt Leute die haben Angst
vor dem Minderheiten die sich zurecht
jetzt eine dafür sorgen sich sich
aufstellen sich gegen die
Diskriminierung wehren dass sie nicht
mehr sagen können was sie wollen das ist
ein Punkt klar liegt das auch in
gewisser Weise in deren Verantwortung
daran zu arbeiten selbstbewusster zu
sein die Backen aufgeblasen wie ein
großer Ballon sorry ich finde wirklich
na also okay also man sieht hier bei
Sylvie wie krass Emotionen sind weil die
wirklich ja auch richtig körperlich
reagiert die Wut ist im Raum fast
greifbar bin wie so ein offenes Buch man
sieht mir alles wirklich in meinem
Gesicht geschrieben ist es einfach da
und ich kann das halt auch ganz schlecht
irgendwie Filtern wenn ich quasi nur
diskriminierende Witze mache um zu
provozieren
ja gut na dann muss ich mich nicht
wundern wenn gegen wenn kommt weil wenn
man so argumentiert dass Diskriminierung
ja gesagt werden darf und dann kein
Gegenwind kommt entschuldige bitte also
so dass ich
wirklich also guck mal Leute immer nur
derjenige was was sagen der ist auch hat
oder das doch sagen du darfst es doch
sagen also das verstehe ich nicht du
darfst das sagen aber du darfst dich am
Ende auch nicht wundern wenn jemand
dagegen hält ich glaube bei dem Punkt
sind wir uns alle einig man darf es
sagen und man darf auch was dagegen
halten die Frage ist jetzt wo wir als
Gesellschaft Grenzen ziehen und das
würde ich gerne einmal mit euch
abstecken wer entscheidet was lustig ist
worüber wir lachen können wo sind wir
die roten Grenzen die roten Linien für
uns helft mir noch einmal mit umzubauen
wir brauchen wieder sehr viel Platz um
jetzt Grenzen abzustellen
die Temperatur zieht an es ist schon
richtig Streit in der Luft aber jetzt
will ich noch mal extremer werden und
das ist eben auch ein Mittel der
Psychologie dass wir an die Grenzen
gehen dahin wo es weh tut und die Idee
ist jetzt dass ihr nacheinander Witze
vorletzt Witze oder einfach wenn man
sowohl auch vielleicht außer überhaupt
nicht lustig aber genau darum geht's ich
will jetzt wissen wo sind die Grenzen
vom Humor und das ganz persönlich eure
Meinung wenn ihr sagt total witzig bin
ich total dabei dann bleibt ihr hier
stehen wenn ihr sagt davon muss ich mich
komplett distanzieren geht ihr auf
dieser Linie immer weiter weg von dem
Witz fangen wir mal mit dir an
kommt ein Blinder in einen Fischladen
hallo Mädels
also ich finde es nicht lustig
finde
wird für mich noch klar gehen dann
dürfte da stehen bleiben genau weiter
bitte schön
Arzt sie sind zu dick Patient ich hole
mir lieber noch eine zweite Meinung Arzt
okay sie sind auch hässlich
du lachst du das auch wieder einen
Schritt zurückgehen ich habe über das
hässlich gelacht weil die private Sylvie
mit ihren Freunden in einem privaten
Raum auch manchmal so Sachen sagt wie
das ist ja voll hässlich oder so einem
witzigen Kontext aber das liegt ja auch
daran guck mal ich muss mich ja selber
auch immer hinterfragen
ich bin ja selber auch nicht frei ich
bin auch keine perfekte Person das heißt
ich musste da auch drüber nachdenken
warum ich gerade gelacht habe wegen
wegen des hässlich das dick fand ich
nicht cool aber das hässlich weil haha
aber irgendwie ne es ist ja auch in mir
drin es ist ja in uns allen drin weil
wir so internalisiert auch wachsen so
aber ich reflektiere mich oder versuche
das wenigstens und okay war nicht genau
also bodyshaming ist nie okay so finde
ich auch trotzdem ist es halt für mich
so ein Witz wo man auch mal schmunzeln
kann das macht sie über dicke lustig und
über hässliche ich würde sagen das
trifft schon jemanden ja natürlich und
da sagst du jetzt ganz ehrlich sehr
ehrlich dass du sagst aber da muss ich
eigentlich doch Lachen oder zum
Schmunzeln ja cool der nicht geht kurz
was das heißt ich habe die zweite
Gedanke zählt ich habe früher ganz
schlimme Witze gelacht also wo ich jetzt
das gar nicht mehr lustig finde
oh Gott
im Kreißsaal nimmt der Arzt das Baby
hoch und haut es mit aller Gewalt auf
die Tischkante dann guckt wer die Mutter
an und sagt verarscht war schon tot boah
ist das egal
ja ist schwierig weil man sich selber
jetzt auch ich will mir halt jetzt
selber dann auch gerade eigentlich den
Raum nehmen mal drüber nachzudenken weil
deswegen bin ich auch eigentlich hier
weil ich hoffe dass man auch durch so
ein Austausch vielleicht ähm so ein
bisschen das Gedankenfeld erweitern kann
wenn das jemand sagen würde jetzt dann
würde ich sagen so krass
aber ich würde jetzt nicht ich würde
denjenigen ich würde jetzt nicht sagen
dass das darfst du nicht sagen du bist
gerade direkt dahinter gegangen weil ich
einfach direkt an Menschen denke oder an
Menschen mit Gebärmutter die ihre Kinder
verloren haben so na also wenn ich jetzt
daran denke dass ich auch in der
KO-Tropfen Situation damit einfach
konfrontiert werde und das gar nicht
kommen habe sehen das ist schon krass
also also das finde ich so krass
geschmacklos ja
Sylvie du bist über den Balken gestiegen
wir haben jetzt einen ich möchte es
nicht Witz nennen aber doch in dem Witze
Forum gefundenen Text den ich euch jetzt
noch mal reingeben möchte es geht um
sexualisierte Gewalt das ist wirklich
heftig ich bin gespannt wie du das
einordnest joyst die du noch nicht über
die Grenze gestiegen bist Zivi bei dir
bin ich auch gespannt
was ist
boah da ist mir wirklich die Spucke
weggeblieben also da
das hat mich halt komplett
emotionalisiert weil ich
halt direkt darüber nachgedacht habe was
eben
Menschen fühlen müssen wenn sie das
Hören und selber in der Kindheit
vergewaltigt wurden
da ist da ist meine persönliche Grenze
schon
ich finde das so krass
was macht mit dir das Joyce da noch
überlegt
habe ich gerade überhaupt keinen Blick
für tatsächlich
schlimm finde
ich finde es auch sehr krass weil es
auch so bildlich ist also ich finde
das schon
ekelhaft weil man weil man direkt so ein
Bild auch vor Augen kriegt hat das noch
irgendwas mit einem Hashtag freedom of
humor zu tun für dich Joyce
also wenn man über Pädophilie und Kirche
Witze macht könnte man ja auch immer
also es machen ja viele und da könnte
man ja auch immer sagen ja dann denkt
man an die ganzen Kinder den sowas
passiert ist ja aber trotzdem ist das
irgendwie gesellschaftlich was anderes
als wenn man sowas setzt das das waren
super emotionaler Moment weil dieser
Witz war in meinen Augen ja auch
wirklich ekelhaft und und also ganz
schlimm und dann habe ich ja selber in
dem Moment gemerkt ja ich habe auch
Grenzen für Humor was vielleicht mir
vorher gar nicht so bewusst war
das ist vielleicht noch mal deswegen
ganz wichtiger Moment auch weil wir
sagen ihr steht beide hinter der Grenze
vielleicht aber aus anderen Motiven
ja wahrscheinlich nehmen wir die Grenze
weg kommt zurück auf die Couch helft mir
gerne noch mal
[Musik]
es gab noch eine Situation auf die ich
eingehen möchte weil es auch ein ein
Witz war zumindest war wieder zuerst so
gedacht der explizit auch mit eurem
ursprünglichen Thema zu tun damit
ursprünglichen wie viel eurem Streit
nämlich darf man jetzt über k.o Tropfen
Witze machen Sylvie als dieser Post kam
in dem wir ganz am Anfang gesprochen
haben hast du da drunter geschrieben bin
fast mal an ko tropfen gestorben ist das
uns erzählt nicht cool Joyce again und
dann melde sich als Comedian und
schreibt dazu Silvia Karlsson also an
dich das nächste Mal werde ich die Dosis
verstärken versprochen
ist das noch Humor
[Musik]
Humor ist ein weiter Begriff vielleicht
könnte man sagen
wir waren eigentlich Smileys noch dabei
[Musik]
er hat auch in der Story noch gegen mich
gehetzt also er hat die Leute dazu
aufgefordert genau da ist die Frage ich
glaube in seinen Augen war das im
weitesten Sinne Humor
erst später gemerkt dass es das gar
nicht war ich glaube dass ihm das aber
vielleicht das er das in dem Moment wo
er das geschrieben hat soweit nicht
reflektiert hat ich finde es krass das
also mir fällt das oft auf dass du sehr
doll dazu geneigt bist mit Tätern
Empathie zu entwickeln er hat sich auch
entschuldigt weil es ihm im Nachhinein
auch total unangenehm ist der hat ja
danach auch noch mal ko tropfen Witze
gemacht auf der Bühne also so leid kann
sie nicht getan haben
zumindestuntergeschrieben das gehört
dazu der Kommentar war drüber es war
keine Morddrohung niemals würde ich
jemandem ko tropfen verabreichen oder
gar vergewaltigen das ist ja absolut
krank und bescheuert mir das zu
unterstellen Unterschied ob jemand sowas
sagt weil oder ob jemand sowas macht ich
finde das so krass dass du es immer
wieder schaffst egal wann die Sache
immer auf dich zu beziehen tut mir echt
leid aber es sind betroffene Menschen
hier und du schaffst es immer wieder am
Ende dich ins Zentrum zu stellen ja ich
stell Fragen dann verstehen möchte
wirklich weil es versucht doch wirklich
ich würde mir so sehr wünschen dass du
dir einmal die Zeit nimmst und
reflektierst was da wirklich passiert
ist und auch reflektiert was wirklich da
falsch gelaufen ist und nicht der erste
Impuls immer wieder ist aber ich aber
wir sind ja hier um beide Perspektiven
auch auszutauschen bei all den Vorwürfen
die im Raum stehen bei all der
Konfrontation die wir hatten dass wir
den Schritt weitergehen und jetzt mal
gucken auch vor allem ganz konkret
bezogen auf worüber dürfen wir jetzt
Schmunzeln was finden wir denn jetzt
lustig wo sind Grenzen wie gehen wir mit
Humor in Deutschland um helft ihm noch
einmal umzubauen
was jetzt kommt wird krass weil wir die
Perspektive einmal komplett wechseln es
ist ziemlich einfach dem anderen
irgendwie Vorwürfe zu machen ich will
jetzt sehen ob Joyce und Silvi die
jeweils andere Perspektive verstanden
haben
egal
[Musik]
viel Konflikt viel Streit und ich würde
jetzt gerne bei all den Vorwürfen
versuchen dass wir auch mal Wünsche
formulieren Ideen formulieren
konstruktiv jetzt überlegen wie können
wir mit Humor in diesem Land umgehen ihr
tauscht jetzt gleich also die Rollen und
dann bitte ich euch
stellvertreten an die ich sag mal Creme
oder Creme der deutschen Comedians
Ansagen zu machen Wünsche zu machen was
ihr euch für den Umgang mit Humor
wünscht was ihr euch vorstellt okay dazu
wirst du zu viel wer fängt an
dann fängt Sylvie an
liebe comedysszene ich würde mir
wünschen dass
der Kontext von Witzen klar wird und das
bei dem Kontext darauf geachtet wird ob
es Minderheiten ob es ein Menschen
verletzt die wirklich schlimme Dinge
auch erlebt haben man kann über die
Grenze wie weit sollte die gehen kann
man immer sprechen aber ich würde mir
wünschen dass ihr euch vor allem über
Themen lustig macht die euch selbst
betreffen die
ja mit denen ihr selber Emotionen und
Verarbeitung verwendet das denke ich wer
der beste Weg damit Comedy auch
gesellschaftlich ein positiven Einfluss
hat
[Musik]
gibt es Applaus dafür ja
[Applaus]
was hat hier noch gefehlt die echte
Silvie und die falsche was hat die
falsche noch vergessen natürlich kann
ich provokante Witze machen ohne Poren
und einfach nur provozieren und nach
unten treten so weil das Aufmerksamkeit
erzeugt aber
was ist dann was was ist das dann für
eine Keime die wollen wir so eine kommen
die und wollen wir auch so eine
Gesellschaft also wollen wir das also
nochmal der klare Appell zu fragen was
willst du mit deiner Comedy auf der
Bühne von oben nach unten
Joyce so richtig jetzt an ganz bewusst
du in deine Rolle bitte tritt doch vor
so ich werde das Feld weil ich mag schon
du gehst ja durch die Haare ja hier rum
trotzdem
okay
ja
hi ach Luke du auch hier
Kollegen Kolleginnen also ehrlich gesagt
die letzte Zeit hatte ich einfach echt
ein bisschen Angst vor dem was ich sagen
darf online und was nicht oder auch in
der Öffentlichkeit und das muss aufhören
wir dürfen keine Angst mehr haben das zu
sagen was uns bewegt und auch was wir
auch der Öffentlichkeit sagen wollen
auch Meinung zu haben auch wenn die
problematisch sind weil wir können ja in
den Austausch gehen auch danach und ich
glaube wenn wir das nicht machen
dann werden immer mehr Leute Angst haben
und am Ende werden wir keinen Austausch
mehr haben und das ist eigentlich mein
Punkt
das heißt jetzt nicht gesehen die echte
Joyce hinter dir nickt über die falsche
Jobs bei dem letzten Satz davor nicht
okay das sollte ja deine Meinung sein
genau
ich habe mich nicht wirklich wieder
erkannt in dem was sie gesagt hat
vielleicht so in Kleinigkeiten
aber darum ging es ja auch nicht man
muss auch in der Comedy Szene
mittlerweile aufpassen also ich würde
niemals sagen so Humor darf keine
Grenzen haben sondern ich möchte mich da
gerne mit befassen kommen wir zurück auf
die Couch und gucken was das mit euch
gemacht hat eben erinnert euch hatte
Sylvie Joyce ganz klar vorgeworfen du
bist nicht empathisch es geht nur um
dich du versetzt Dich nicht in dich
hinein jetzt gerade beim Rollentausch
hätte ich das Gefühl es ist genau das
Gegenteil passiert Joyce war plötzlich
die die unglaublich empathisch war in
ihrer Rolle als Sylvie als Joyce gerade
gesagt hat Humor darf darf Grenzen haben
unter Umständen gemeinsam überlegen darf
dass man Angst hat darüber zu sprechen
und dass da so ein Prozess angestoßen
ist hast habe ich auch gesagt was hat
das mit dir gemacht
ja ich finde diesen Angst Punkt valide
ich frage mich nur aus welcher Position
das heraus passiert also ist es weil
Menschen nicht verstehen dass es
diskriminierend ist irgendwie
ableistische Witze zu machen so was ich
halt merke ist dass Menschen teilweise
Bewegungen wo sie eigentlich dahinter
stehen wo sie sagen ich finde das Ziel
was die Leute haben finde ich ja gut
aber die Art wie das angegangen wird ist
mir irgendwie zu aggressiv das ist gar
nicht auf dich bezogen dann sehen die so
eine Masse an negativen Kommentaren das
ist den dann ähm zu viel und dadurch
bewegen sie sich sogar wieder von dieser
Bewegung weg weil ihnen die Art wie das
umgesetzt wird teilweise zu extrem ist
Sylvie fällt mir auf dass die Joyce
hierhin kommt und sagt ich will mit dir
reden ich bin offen für Dialog und Silvi
die ganze Zeit signalisiert ich beweg
mich aber eigentlich keinen Zentimeter
Joy sagt immer wieder ganz klar ich bin
hier um zu sprechen ich will sprechen es
geht mir um Dialog was mir da fehlt ist
was sie dann auch in ihrem Verhalten
ändern will also ich finde es total
schön dass wir heute dieses offene
Gespräch haben und ich sehe mich ja eh
eher so in der Mitte stehen bei dem
Thema jetzt einfach so ich sage ja nicht
Mord keine Grenzen sondern ich sage lass
gucken wo die sind so also deswegen sehe
ich mich ja gar nicht auf der
gegenüberliegenden Seite jetzt
vielleicht von Sylvie sondern schon so
ja das finde ich schönen Gedanken
rutschen also na wie du es mein Ziel wie
sieht's noch maximal in ihrer Ecke du
bist schon ein bisschen auf sie
zugegangen glaube ich ein ganz guter
Moment und zum Schluss zu kommen
[Musik]
ihr beiden zum Schluss eine Sache wo ich
jetzt nicht sicher bin ob die
funktioniert bin sehr gespannt stellt
euch doch mal bitte gegenüber in der
Mitte hier dieses Raumes auf reicht euch
die Hände
ich wollte noch eine Schippe drauflegen
schaffen wir eine Umarmung
bitte und nicht auflösen weil jetzt
kommt eine letzte kleine Bitte Challenge
ich möchte zwei Sachen von euch hören
wir sind heute gestartet mit im Prinzip
einer Frage darf man über KO-Tropfen
Witze machen und ihr solltet nur in
einem Wort Antworten das jetzt bitte
noch mal darf man über KO-Tropfen Witze
machen Silvia
kommt auf den Kontext an Joyce ich
wollte auch nein sagen und dann wünsche
ich mir von euch beiden noch einen Satz
den ihr der anderen mitgibt eine Message
Sylvie
für Joyce also ich würde mir wirklich
wünschen dass du auch die Perspektive
von betroffenen Menschen wahrnimmst und
das auch reflektierst und auch wenn wir
alle Fehler machen
auch da vielleicht erstmal kurz in nicht
gehst und überlegst okay was ist jetzt
bei mir
was habe ich vielleicht jetzt nicht so
optimal nach außen getragen
tauschen war Joyce jetzt du
an selfie du setzt dich ja für super
vieler Themen ein und das finde ich auch
gut immer wenn man sich für Dinge die
einem wichtig sind einsetzt und sich
selber ausdrückt finde ich super cool
und vielleicht
würde ich mir wünschen oder finde ich
schön wenn du da dann auch noch mehr in
den Austausch gehen wird es in Zukunft
so wie heute so dass weil ich glaube
dass das halt vielleicht c-führend ist
auch erste Sitzung auf der Couch ich
glaube wir haben so viel geschafft
Abschluss Umarmung und dann sind wir
durch
Joyce vielen Dank dass du da warst
weiter alles Gute genauso bis dahin
danke für die Diskussion tschüss
zusammen
ich muss sagen dass ich schon auch den
Eindruck hatte vor dass sie schon
eher unreflektiert an die Sache
rangegangen ist
und jetzt war ich doch irgendwie positiv
überrascht dass sie mit mir so offen
gesprochen hat ich hoffe dass das was
sie heute gesagt hat dass wir das ernst
nehmen können klar kann man heute nicht
alle Sachen lösen vielleicht
untereinander aber ich fand das ein
richtig wichtigen und guten ersten
Schritt
wenn ich mir eins für diese Folge
wirklich gewünscht habe dann dass die
genauso emotional und authentisch wird
wie dieser Streit gerade eben und bei
allem streiten gab es doch auch immer
wieder Annäherung es gab Momente wo wir
glaube ich ein völlig neuen Blickwinkel
bekommen haben auf dieses wichtige auf
dieses heftige Thema wenn du das auch so
siehst Teil dieses Video damit genau das
Thema mehr Leute erreicht
[Musik]